you guys are [ __ ] with me though
right like I don't actually need all
this stuff this is overkill today we're
learning from Michelle Phan I've never
put on makeup for myself I have two
sisters who tortured me with makeup I am
doing Michelle Phan's midnight lust I am
doing how to look like a kpop star
putting on makeup for a romantic day I
chose the wedding tutorial because on my
wedding day my wife spent like hours
doing her hair and makeup this already
looks extremely difficult light weight
brunette brown gel there are so many
brushes do women actually own this much
makeup because that's crazy
it's concealer like a one size fits all
she's making her wider Vietnamese eyes
look pointy or like my Korean hands like
combing my eyebrow never done that
before no no this is too bright getting
ready for a football game that's how I'm
gonna make this gender normative this is
basically exactly what Michelle Phan was
doing do women spend this long on just
the eyes or am i just dumb you know I'm
so upset about is that Eugene is gonna
be so good at this because he had
sisters as long as I'm prettier than
Zack I'll be okay it's very possible
I've been using the wrong one the whole
time to apply the foundation normally
it's not a descriptor next time a friend
asked me to come with her to Sephora and
I'm like really impatient and getting
angry at about how long it looks I'm
just gonna shut the [ __ ] up like I get
it now I get it
oh I touched my eyeball with it stab my
eyeball myself and yeah I don't know why
my solution is to just make it bigger
but it is oh yeah and stateliest X here
beauty is paying beauty is paying
beauty's pain oh I broke it i torture
complete nope I've seen videos online
where girls chop off their eyelashes
doing this this isn't right but it's
something look at me now mom everything
you wanted here's the beauty shot do I
look beautiful
yes did my wife look better on her
wedding day
absolutely I just looked like a pretty
guy who couldn't maybe make it in a kpop
band that's okay with lipstick and eye
glitter I knew it was like something
that took an hour I didn't think it was
something too
made you stressed for an hour I just
look like a confused glittery panda I
feel like I could practice this for
years and still be terrible at it your
hair is [ __ ] eejit your hair you're
eating your hair your hair is what I did
the hair again it's really it's just I
don't think you realize how small my
head is on how large your hair